[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing both peter pettigrew
and lord voldemort more specifically
however we're going to be identifying
why on earth lord voldemort continued to
call pettigrew by his marauder nickname
now one thing is for certain voldemort
and wormtail
certainly don't have a lot in common but
one thing they
do have in common is that they use an
alias that deviates from their birth
name
voldemort was born tom riddle but chose
the name voldemort to shed
his muggle father's name and wormtail
was born
peter pettigrew but was donned wormtail
by his fellow marauders
the difference however is that peter
pettigrew was really only known as
wormtail
by his inner circle where voldemort
became widely known under his new alias
so again why did voldemort call
pettigrew by his nickname
from the group of marauders comprised of
sirius black
remus lupin james potter and peter
pettigrew pettigrew was the defector
all four boys began attending hogwarts
in the year 1971
and each of them were sorted into
gryffindor this was the initial basis of
their friendship
a friendship that held strong for many
years but certainly not forever
the marauders were hell-bent on breaking
the rules at the school
and were notorious for their rule
breaking and mischief making
the group existed for seven years from
1971 to 1978
and all members were active participants
in the first wizarding war
the boys formed such a strong bond that
they all had nicknames for each other
mooney padfoot wormtail and prongs
though the four boys were friends
wormtail was always a bit different than
the other marauders
less magically talented a bit more
snively and
just a bit of an outsider he had a weak
character
and this is exemplified in the actions
that he took later
in life but we'll get to that in a
second of course despite wormtale's weak
character he never did anything to raise
too many alarm bells
and so the three other marauders stuck
by his side
they all eventually joined the order of
the phoenix and while petaku proved
trustworthy at first this all changed
when he was made
secret keeper for the potter family
after being made secret keeper
peter pettigrew revealed his true
colours and in one infamous act of
cowardice and disloyalty
revealed the location of the potter
cottage to voldemort it was at this
moment that this sniveling
disloyal man had secured his placement
as a death eater
a loyal servant of the dark lord you see
peter had a tendency to cling to those
in power
which in his school days were the
marauders and later was voldemort
after graduating from hogwarts he
witnessed the rise of voldemort first
hand
and out of fear and cowardice decided
that he would rather serve voldemort
than become another one of his victims
something unusual that i noticed however
is that even after switching sides
voldemort along with many of the death
eaters continued to call him by his
marauder's name wormtail i don't think
they called him the name wormtail
unintentionally either they were making
a statement
i think that among other reasons
voldemort called pettigrew wormtail
to remind him of the people that he had
betrayed wormtail
already lacked strength of character and
reminding him of his betrayal
only kept him further in line ensuring
that he would never have the mental
strength to question his bidding
it was a demonstration of power and
dominance and while the childhood
nickname
may have been fun during his time at
hogwarts it wasn't a name that fit a
wizard in
adulthood it was humiliating broken
apart the words worm
and tail don't exactly command respect
either
a constant reminder of his animagus form
a rat
i think another component to voldemort
using the name wormtail was that it
dehumanized pettigrew relegating him to
his animal status
whichever way you look at it the name
worm tell certainly wasn't used warmly
it was just a constant reminder of the
terrible person he had become
and that's it for this video if you
enjoyed the video please like it and
subscribe to the channel
until next time what would you have done
sirius
you